the sushi science show clips
yeah I mean that does kind of make sense
to me as well but you've already brought
up kind of like where I was heading um
in my thought process with the questions
which is this idea about these wearable
um biosensities biodomes I believe you
call them um and you've done uh
experiments in particular with frogs
called Santa purse where you've
amputated their limbs and you've got
them to wear these biodoms and you can
see um regeneration of their limbs and
not only that but they're also
potentially functional as well and this
paper I believe came out earlier this
year
um and I was just wondering if maybe you
could elaborate a bit more about what
these these biodomes actually are and
how they're functioning yeah yeah um
we've actually had a couple of papers on
this was one in in in well there was a
there was a an earlier one uh in 2018
and then and then there was this one
that just came out the idea is this we
we are we are very interested in uh
morphogenesis as a collective
intelligence so we're interested in not
micromanaging the process and let's say
3D printing a bunch of stem cells into a
very particular structure we're
interested in understanding how the
collective of the cells normally makes
decisions about what it's going to grow
when it's going to grow and so on and so
our strategy what what we think should
be possible is if if these hypotheses
are correct what should be possible is
to find high level triggers that don't
sort of babysit the process and try to
control everything that needs to happen
to make an organ but actually just shift
the the the the the set point for these
cells and then let them do what they do
best which is to reduce error and to
build to the set point so activate that
homeostatic process
so we started so we started looking for
these uh for these high level uh control
control structures and I could tell you
about others that we found by studying
by electricity so we make eyes and
repairing brain defects and reprogram
tumors so we can talk about that
separately but for the leg thing we
basically found uh and this was this was
uh back in 2010 we did we did uh we
published some work showing that you can
induce tail regeneration now tails are
cool because they have spinal cord and
muscle and so on so we showed that we
can induce tail regeneration uh just by
one hour of application of this specific
ionophore so setting setting the
bioelectric state of the wound uh using
a sodium ionophore but just for one hour
triggers all the downstream Cascades all
the gene expression cell movement all
that stuff so we looked for the same we
used the
um uh the same uh kind of uh we use the
same kind of cocktails and some
different ones and the idea was in order
to trigger it you need really two things
you need an environment to convince
those cells that it's safe to regenerate
right so you need some sort of very
controlled closed environment that's
almost like amniotic almost like a limb
bud you know
um and that they would be able to signal
to each other and not get washed out in
the in the bath and so on and then and
then you need the payload which is the
signal the drugs that cause the signal
right the the so the biodome is the
delivery method and it's the environment
but now you need to have some kind of a
drug in there that will activate them
and so we're working on a variety of uh
but by the way I have to I have to do a
disclosure so David Kaplan and I are
um co-founders of a company called
morpheuticals Inc so zomorphosuticals is
all about taking what we've learned in
the Frog and moving it into into the
mammals so we're doing experiments in
mice now and then hopefully Clinic you
know clinical work at some point so so
every you know I have to have to do that
that disclosure and there's a commercial
interest here so the idea so so the idea
is that
um we David's group created the biodome
the biodome is filled with an aqueous
gel that's made of silk and that gel has
various other drugs that that we put in
there it's put on the amputation wound
for 24 hours just just one day that's it
24 hours
and then you take it off and you don't
touch the animals again and leg grows
over a year and a half so you get a year
and a half of light right so so there's
a few amazing things I think about about
this number one animals that normally do
not regenerate their legs as adults in
fact can be made to regenerate their
legs as adults right that's even
possible it wasn't known before that
that's possible so it's possible number
two uh it's a very modular effect in
other words we didn't intervene with the
finely shaped gradients for a year and a
half we did nothing after the first 24
hours the animal did everything okay so
so it's a very it's a trigger it's not
um it's not it's not a micromanagement
type of situation number three
um in that trigger
uh we didn't even have to
specify what organ we want the the the
trigger cocktail is very generic in fact
we've done the exact same thing to make
Tails as it was to make I had to make
legs it's literally a make whatever
belongs here signal it's not make a leg
so so you never get in on a leg
amputation you never get an eye or a
tumor or a tail or you know anything
else you always get what belongs it like
so it's very context sensitive process
we're not forcing this elsewhere
communicating to them that they should
make whatever it is that they already
know goes there the last and then the
last kind of amazing thing about it is
that this cocktail that was the first
one we tried it wasn't cocktail 78 out
of like 300 cocktails that we tried we
didn't have I mean originally one of the
limitations of this work is originally I
I foolishly thought that this was going
to be a rapid screening process that we
could use before you know and it's it's
it's it's not rapid by any means and so
we only got to try one cocktail but the
one cocktail we tried was amazing and so
I you know I I'm I don't believe in luck
and so to me that's that that suggests
that it's not that we just happen to
have uh somehow lucked out onto the best
cocktail in the world once we optimize
this thing we're really going to see uh
remarkable outcomes this is just this is
our first guess at it you know this is
just a first step
yeah no that really is quite incredible
and you've just raised a couple of
questions on my head firstly it's like
how CNG have to intervene after you've
like induced the damage and like is
there like because I guess you have to
uh quickly maybe induce the pattern
before you suppress like the the more
like scarring of the tissue and then
secondly what was the rationale behind
the decision of the drugs that you used
yeah so uh I I don't know when is the
latest that you can do it we don't know
in older work in the tale we did
investigate this and we find out that we
found out that even after the tail of
wound forms what in for the frog is the
equivalent of a wound of a scar so it's
basically like this thick non-permissive
epithelium even after that it still
works I have a feeling that in mammals
what you would have to do is you would
have to re-cut so if somebody had if
somebody had a limb loss 10 years ago
and everything's healed over I think
you're gonna have to reopen the wound
then put on the biodome and then go from
there that's my guess we don't know but
that's that's that's what I think
um
the uh the choice of the choice of drugs
so
in previous work we had done a few
things we we had we had uh tested a
couple of bioelectric interventions
which are kind of the thing my lab
focuses on
um we've also done progesterone the 2018
paper was about progesterone and that
was because uh the postdoc at the time
uh Celia Herrera Rincon wanted to go
upstream and try to find something that
triggers not only the right
bioelectrical signal but various other
changes in the animal that that might be
pro-regenerative so she went with
progesterone and it was and that was
shockingly effective right the new the
new cocktail which is even better has a
number of ingredients which again not
specifically bioelectric this time now
we're doing a bunch of by electric stuff
next but this particular one had things
like
you know it had a it had it had uh
neurotrophic factors in it and it had
growth hormone and it had retinoic acid
which is a positional information
molecule for for the limb and it had
um a uh uh kind of a a resolve and you
know so so so so Pro wound resolution
kind of the kind of molecule and so on
so it was kind of it was kind of mix a
mix of things that we thought would
would convince the cells that it's time
to regenerate as opposed to you know as
opposed to scar and yeah it worked
really well and I mean I can't wait to
to to get to try all the different
improvements that you can imagine right
after the first trial yeah for sure and
I think you already sort of mentioned it
but as you say you have the bioreactor
on for 24 hours and then it takes like a
year for it to recreate the limb and so
in terms of scalability it's quite hard
to maybe I guess scale up and try
different intentions but I guess given
the remarkable result from doing your
first approach then that I guess gives a
lot of promise for identifying
um get better and better combinations as
well
yeah yeah I mean at this point at this
point uh we're in mice now we're doing
it in mice now but I think there's
probably not uh well if I mean if
resources were unlimited there's still
frog things to be done but but but given
given how long that takes and and
limited resources which is going for
mice at this point
um which which also you know which also
take a little bit of time I mean I you
know in the end in terms of Clinic
clinical um uh kind of import look uh uh
uh
a five-year-old's arm is very usable
right you can write you can shave you
can you can eat you can do whatever
you're gonna do so if somebody if
somebody in their 20s it loses an arm in
an accident somewhere and you think that
okay five to seven years later you have
an arm that you can you can type and you
can do everything with that's pretty
good that's a good deal even if even if
it you know even even if even if it
grows no faster than a typical arm you
know a kid's a kid's arm is very usable
so I think I think in the end even worst
case scenario I think it'll be fine
yeah for sure and like in terms of I
guess as you mentioned translating it to
humans what kind of like criteria or
like tick list of achievements do we
need to see before we actually start
giving it as a human therapy so
well there's a there's a long road I
mean lots of lots lots and lots of basic
research needs to happen right so I I
don't want to give the idea that we're
sort of ready to start testing it on
humans because we're absolutely not
um
fundamentally there's a number of things
I mean a just to show in mammals that we
can deal with all of the things that are
different you know the blood pressure
the the infection risk the more complex
uh you know um inflammatory response the
bigger uh the bigger diameter of the of
the of the of the limb itself you know
all of these things have to be have to
be dealt with um some things will be
easier you know humans won't be chewing
off the the biodome the way the mice try
to do so so certain you know certain
things will be will be easier but but
there's a there's a lot there's a lot
that remains still but the you know
we're on the way yeah for sure and one
thing that I think is kind of intriguing
about this approach is as you sort of
mentioned it's the idea that we don't
necessarily need to fully understand the
downstream molecular details of exactly
how it's coordinating it we just have to
like intervene I guess that's a higher
level and the reason that I think that's
interesting is because there's a lot of
I guess interest at the moment in terms
of like personalized genomic approaches
to healthcare and I guess
um this Approach at least at first
glance appears to be something that
might be more Universal and maybe the
same set of treatments could be abides
more broadly and I guess do you think
that's the case or do you think there
would still be an element of like
personalization uh to what like the drug
combination could be
there there is there is going to be an
element of personalization only because
uh in particular with the bioelectric
treatments you're going to want to know
in your particular patient which
channels are expressed in the wound and
that may differ somewhat person to
person but we'll find out but but you're
right fundamentally in that this is a
much more generic approach for the
following reason in any control
structure the further up you go
the less you have to worry about the
details because the whole point of a
hierarchical control structure is that
the details are delegated so if if you
know if you tell seven different people
um you know uh go get me a coffee they
may do it completely differently but and
you don't but the point is you don't
need to uh specify well you're going to
move your right foot three inches this
way then you're gonna you don't need to
do any of that because you're dealing
with competent agents that know how to
do certain things and you don't have to
worry about your message is exactly the
same even though in each person the
molecular details right of what they
hear how they carry it out what what
chemicals go where in their brain when
they hear it those are all different but
but you're up at a higher level and so
it's uh
addressing addressing these kinds of
things at higher levels has lots of
advantages
um and one of the advantages is that
by by
taking advantage of the fact that you're
working with a competent material that
already knows how to do things you can
leave a lot of the details uh up to the
implementation so so you're not going to
uh have to worry about which which
channels are open when you're going to
set a set of bioelectric states and let
let the system go from there that that I
think you know that that part is going
to be the same for everybody and and
then and then different very very
different things what will happen
Downstream
that's right yeah that makes sense
um and just one kind of last aspect
whilst we're talking about regeneration
so is um and contrasting that to the
more wound healing and scarring approach
is that one of my interest is in I guess
the Circadian rhythm and how there seems
to be some differences and I guess like
the downstream processes at different
times of the day and in particular with
green healing I know that there is like
an emerging area of research showing
that depending on the time of the day
when the wound occurs like the healing
process can look out at different speeds
and so I was just wondering if you've
looked at all into any of the time of
day links with these regenerative
approaches it's a fascinating question
uh you're right and and even for example
now they're finding that for
chemotherapy it uh it really depends
when you get it because because the
cycling of the stem cells and also of
the cancer cells is related to uh the
the time of day and so on uh we don't we
don't know very much about it we're
studying it there's a there's a there's
a postdoc in the group who's studying
time time keeping in the context of a
DARPA project on slowing biological time
for injuries and stuff like that and so
so she's working on this but we we don't
know much about it yet it's still early
days